[Musique]
on commence donc par cette phrase choc
des manuels macro non parisiens les non
vaccinés j'ai très envie de les en
dernier c'est tout sauf un dérapage ce
sont des propos prémédité organisé d'un
cynisme pur il après les 100 dans de
françois hollande voit là le je vais les
emmerder d'emmanuel macron je pense que
l'homme le mieux placé pour devenir
président en 22 c'est gilles de la
tourette qui ont toutes les qualités il
retombe dans son penchant à son penchant
naturel qui est de se réfugier dans la
provocation dans l'insulté parce que la
réalité c'est que c'est un président
faible qui ne s'est jamais choisir cette
année elle commence avec évidemment non
pas de la bienveillance et l'ol macron a
laissé tous à investir et bien longtemps
mais un mépris des français une violence
vis-à-vis des français parfois le
président l'a publics s'engagent de feu
s'exprime de façon soutenue par fois
cette façon familière là il s'est
exprimé de façon familière tout le monde
a compris ce qu'il voulait entendre ce
n'est pas au président de la république
de trier entre les bons et les mauvais
français il faut les accepter tels
qu'ils sont il faut les diriger les
rassembler sans les insultes et une
faute morale lourde dans un pays qu'il a
contribué très lourdement à fracturer on
est passé de détecter traces va tester
pardon tracé isolé à détester tracé
emmerder c'est à dire qu'il fait de la
vaccination à référendum pour ou contre
mâcon il en fait un plébiscite ça c'est
une faute politique
ce sont des propos qui déshonorent sa
fonction qui montre son incapacité
son danger qui gâchent la vie de nos
soignants qui depuis deux ans sont
mobilisés sous l'eau dans nos services
de réanimation pour sauver des patients
qui aujourd'hui sont essentiellement non
vaccinés ce sont ceux qui s'opposent aux
accents ce qu'a dit le président de la
république
je l'entend partout
mais oui et bien sûr que oui et vous le
savez vous le savez il ya une forme
d'exaspération de nos concitoyens qui
gâchent la vie de nos commerçants de nos
restaurateurs de nos théâtres de nos
cinémas qui depuis deux ans vivent avec
une épée de damoclès au-dessus de la
tête quand ils n'ont pas été fermées ce
sont ceux qui s'opposent aux vaccins
présent la république a pris cette
référence celle du président georges
pompidou qui disait il faut arrêter
d'emmerder les français on imagine mal
de gaulle venir dire qu'il va venir
emmerder les français bon mais ça c'est
les mots qui vous choque plus presque
pour moi c'est la suite un irresponsable
n'est plus un citoyen c'est une faute
républicaine majeur j'espère que dans 95
jours et shoklan et à dormir des
personnes mais j'ai acheté la démocratie
l'idée biologistes en chef de l'agencé
danoise de contrôle des maladies
infectieuses chez pas si vous avez vous
l'avez lu vous avez vues plongeantes a
lieu c'est des gens sachent que dans
deux mois tour deviendra normal c'est ce
qu'il dit pas écouté on souhaite tous
qu'il ait raison alors en guadeloupe le
directeur du chu a été séquestré est
exfiltré par la police ces dernières
heures toute façon c'est tout ce que
cette épidémie on a des bases
historiques
on sait que ça va durer trois à cinq ans
balle à rentrer dans la troisième année
maintenant donc oui on en arrive vers la
fin j'ai été extrait avec un coup de
poing dans les côtes et un énorme coup
sur la tête j'ai perdu connaissance
pendant 10 secondes je pense m'a déchiré
ma chemise j'ai reçu lui rinne sur moi
pendant que je courais à la police je
pense très possible effectivement que le
virus se soit échappé du laboratoire du
wan et pire encore que ces travaux ont
été financés par les américains comme ça
a été dit par le new york times croit ou
le herald tribune je sais plus dans les
jambes
[Musique]